foreign
Charlotte is in Lexington Kentucky hey
Charlotte how are you
hello how are you better than we deserve
what's up
um my question is how do you start the
emergency fund when you're behind on
multiple bills each month you don't
sounds like you got a mess kiddo what's
going on
um yeah I do um
36 single two kids
um I've been working two jobs for almost
five years now
um and I just cannot get caught up to
stay current on all my bills let alone
start emergency funds
I hear you
so what do you make
um what I bring foam each month between
both jobs is 3 200.
um my my debt if I make the minimum
payments each month is
um 1900
and so that leaves me about how much how
much is your rent
um so I have a mortgage and it's 560 a
month okay that's good news
and um are you getting child support
um yes but not
why
and he just chooses to pay it when it's
convenient to him
well the courts in Kentucky will help
him with his discipline you know that
right and they've actually sent
something to garnish wages here recently
so good good
that didn't fix the problem but it just
fixes my aggravation at him and I'm just
joining you in that
um how old are your babies
I'm 15 and 11. for 12 13
15. Lord so they ate a lot
especially during the summer yeah so
what kind of debts have you got
um car payment how much do you owe on
the car
sixteen thousand
and um
and what else
um student loans are about 16 000 when
you add them all up
um I have
I've lived life and went on a cruise in
April and so I'm paying on my how much
do you owe on the cruise
uh sixteen hundred
and
I've got two like a firm loans one's for
a mattress and one's for tires
how much are those and how much are
those
oh
and my
pie so my tires are about 700 and then
the mattress I owe like 200 on
okay
and then I've got uh my braces that that
I owe about 3 200 on
[Music]
and then medical bills that I probably
owe about
um
probably about six thousand dollars
inside of our how long you been single
you said
um it's about 10 years
what do you do for your jobs Charlotte
um I am a quality manager and I've
actually had a conduit and I've been
there 18 years and then on my server at
Cracker Barrel and I've been there
almost five years okay
all right um
let me give you a couple of observations
I've been doing this a long time so I've
sat with people in your situation a lot
okay
um
you've been
um living on nothing right on the edge
scared
for a long time
and that has caused you to give yourself
permission
to do some stupid things that have made
it worse
okay
yeah like a sixteen thousand dollar car
you can't afford because the other old
car was breaking down all the time and
you couldn't handle that extra fear
added with all the fear you already had
so you said I'm gonna get at least one
thing in my life that is reliable
because this guy paying child support
certainly isn't
that's 100 True just in October that
happened yeah and um and then you got
well I'm not gonna get out anyway I
might as well live my life so I'm going
on the cruise oh and then the dadgum
tires go out so we gotta have tires
because you can't roll this sixteen
thousand dollar car without a tire
foreign
right and so what happens is we end up
going from crisis to crisis because
we're trapped
and
um so we got to get out of this but it's
going to be radical
are you ready
I'm I'm ready
we're gonna go with you Ben's not
working yeah I'll hold my hand we're
going to jump off it wasn't an evil
laugh from him
hold my hand we're gonna jump off the
cliff together here we go and uh the
water's cold and it's deep so we're okay
get ready to jump here we go it's gonna
be different here we go run back here we
go that's what I'm laughing about okay I
will go with you we're going to help you
and I'm gonna put people around you I'm
going to give you a financial coach free
of charge I'm going to pay for it
because I can't stand how trapped you
are it's driving me crazy okay uh and
then I'm gonna pile a bunch of books on
you that I need you to read all of them
and turn your stupid television off
okay okay one of them is on Career from
paycheck to purpose I'm gonna give you
two of them from Ken Coleman and I want
you to go to a Ken he's our he's our
career expert because you don't make
nothing
and I want you to go get a job making
twice what you're making now you're
worth a whole lot more than you're
getting paid
okay well I tried to tell my boss that
well he ain't listening you've been
there a long time and so it's time to
start looking at it it's time to retool
reset your mind uh comb your hair out
and get ready to go on an interview girl
here we go all right okay because you
need to go make some more money you've
been starving a long time
and um uh so I'm going to send you a
bunch of career books and Ken Coleman is
our career guy I'm gonna send you one on
proximity principle ones from paycheck
to purpose read them both okay uh we're
going to put you into Financial Peace
University which is our nine week class
and take your 15 year old with you it's
nine lessons you can either do it online
or you can do it local church either one
we're going to pay for all this you
don't call it gonna cost you a dime I
just want you to go do it all
because my heart's hurting for you okay
okay I get where you are I I know
exactly where you are and how how tired
you are and uh you got a new friend
that's going to help you and Rachel and
me okay and thank you you're probably
gonna sell your car
because you can't afford this car this
car payment is the car payment is what
drowning you you got a great mortgage
your mortgage is awesome your car
payment is horrible
probably killing you and then you ain't
doing any more stupid stuff like cruises
and you're not eating out you're not
going to reward you you're going to
clean up this dad gum mess and you're
gonna work your butt off like never
before
and it's going to be for a short period
of time and this time we're actually
going to get some traction and move the
needle instead of spinning our Wheels
all the time because you've been
spinning your wheels for a decade so got
this Charlotte you hang on we're going
to get you with a coach we're gonna get
you the books we're going to get you
into FPU and you're going to call us
back if you need some help hang on